Au début de la trentaine,
Marx vit à Londres.
Il sait qu’il est surveillé
par des espions prussiens.
Un de ces espions réussit à obtenir sa confiance
en se faisant passer pour un militant.
Marx l’invite chez lui.
Voici ce que l’espion
écrira dans son rapport :
« Marx mène une vie de bohème. Rarement il se lave
et change de sous-vêtements. Il est facilement
soûl. Il traîne souvent toute la journée ; mais,
s'il a du travail, il s'y adonne jour et nuit.
Il n'a pas d'horaires pour dormir et se lever.
Souvent il reste debout toute la nuit et la
matinée, puis se couche vers midi sur un canapé,
tout habillé, et dort jusqu'au soir sans tenir
compte des allées et venues autour de lui. »
Ce sont les idées de CET HOMME qui ont
changé le monde au XXe siècle ?
Vous connaissez peut-être
cette citation de Marx :
« Les philosophes n’ont fait qu’interpréter le
monde de diverses manières ; ce qui importe,
c’est de le transformer. »
Bon eh bien, il a suivi sa
propre recommandation.
Aucun homme n'a exercé sur le
monde une influence comparable à celle
que Karl Marx a eue au XXe siècle.
Et nous vivons encore sous son influence.
C’est donc crucial, pour comprendre le monde,
de comprendre COMMENT les idées de
Marx ont germé dans son esprit.
Comment un homme qui n’a
jamais mis un pied dans une
usine est devenu le prophète des ouvriers.
Mais vous allez voir que Marx n’est
pas pour autant un imposteur.
Je vais vous raconter 10 anecdotes
étonnantes et révélatrices sur sa vie.
C’est parti !
« Les chiens ne font pas
des chats », dit l’adage.
Ce n’est pas TOUJOURS vrai,
mais ça l’est pour Marx.
Un de ses principaux traits de personnalité,
c’est la curiosité, l’appétit intellectuel.
Il s’intéresse à tous les champs du savoir ; à
tous les pays ; à toutes les époques.
D’ailleurs, la biographie que j’ai lue pour
faire cette vidéo s’intitule Karl
Marx ou l’esprit du monde.
Eh bien, Karl tient son appétit intellectuel
de son père, Heinrich Marx.
Cet avocat est passionné de politique.
Au point que, malgré la censure qui règne dans la
Prusse de l’époque, il crée un club intellectuel
qui réunit la bourgeoisie éclairée à Trèves.
Il parle de philosophie, de littérature,
de politique et des dernières innovations
scientifiques avec des négociants, des notables,
et même des profs de philo. Ils évoquent aussi
les premières communautés socialistes
créées au début du XIXe siècle.
Et Heinrich, cet homme d’une grande curiosité
intellectuelle, a une relation très forte avec
son fils depuis son plus jeune âge.
À l’adolescence, Karl a déjà des
conversations profondes avec son père.
Il lui fait découvrir les grands économistes de
l’époque (comme le comte de Saint-Simon).
Karl rencontre aussi les membres du club
intellectuel de son père — et bien
sûr il s’enrichit à leur contact.
Ce que montre cette anecdote, c’est que
le génie intellectuel de Karl Marx est le
fruit d’une stimulation précoce.
À la vérité, c’est la même chose dans
tous les domaines : qu’il s’agisse de musique, de
football, ou de la pensée, l’excellence est très
souvent le résultat d’une stimulation précoce —
la plupart du temps exercée par les parents.
Les sœurs de Marx racontent qu’enfant, il
les obligeait à dévaler une colline alors
qu’il était à cheval sur leur dos.
Il les forçait aussi à manger des gâteaux
dégoûtants qu’il avait lui-même confectionnés avec
une pâte sale — et elles lui obéissaient.
Mais pourquoi est-ce qu’elles
lui obéissaient ?
Parce qu’elles voulaient à tout prix
qu’il leur raconte des histoires.
Elles disent qu’il avait un
incroyable talent de conteur,
au point qu’elles en étaient dépendantes
— un peu comme nous pouvons, aujourd’hui, être
dépendants de certaines séries sur Netflix.
D’après ses sœurs, Marx a une personnalité
exceptionnelle dès l’enfance.
Il rayonne ; il marque les
gens et les attire à lui.
C’est ce qu’on appelle le charisme.
Ça sera également le cas à
l’université, où son père
l’envoie étudier le droit quand il a 17 ans.
Si Marx n’est pas imposant physiquement — il est
de taille et de corpulence moyennes —, il
cultive un style particulier : il soigne
son abondante chevelure et se laisse
déjà pousser une petite barbe.
Mais surtout, sa personnalité s’imprime
dans l’esprit de ses camarades parce
qu’il fait tout de façon extrême :
le travail, les nuits blanches, les violences
verbales et physiques… et l'alcool.
Il multiplie les soirées ; il se bat.
Il achète même un pistolet pour
se protéger de ses rivaux.
Ce que montre cette anecdote, c’est que
la diffusion des idées de Marx est aussi
le fruit de son charisme personnel.
Il rencontrera beaucoup d’intellectuels
tout au long de sa vie, et le magnétisme
de sa personnalité, de sa confiance en lui,
le charisme avec lequel il leur
exposera ses thèses fera beaucoup
pour leur adoption et leur diffusion.
Et j’irais même plus loin : Marx n’est pas
seulement un penseur charismatique, il y a
aussi en lui un leader charismatique, un meneur
d’hommes qui sait imposer sa volonté.
Depuis les mauvais traitements qu’il fait
subir à ses sœurs en passant par les
associations universitaires, il aime
commander dans tout ce qu'il entreprend.
Cette qualité lui permettra notamment de créer
l'organisation communiste internationale.
Un agent secret qui a infiltré l’entourage de
Marx note qu’il est entouré de compagnons
prêts à tout pour le servir.
À la fac de droit de Bonn, Marx
dépense sans compter tout l’argent
que lui envoie son père.
Pire : il contracte en seulement
quelques mois des dettes considérables (que
son père remboursera en protestant).
C’est comme ça que commence la relation
complexe de Marx avec l'argent.
D’abord, il ne cherche pas à
gagner beaucoup d’argent.
Il considère que c’est une forme d’esclavage (il
parle d’« aliénation » dans sa théorie).
Du coup, il sera pauvre
l’essentiel de sa vie.
Lui, ça ne lui fait pas grand-chose
— mais il culpabilise de laisser
sa famille dans la misère.
Sa femme, ses enfants, et lui doivent
parfois s’entasser dans des logements exigus
et insalubres (à Londres, notamment).
Il est soulagé lorsque des rentrées
d’argent leur permettent de retrouver
un minimum de confort.
Mais malheureusement,
il se remet à vivre au-dessus de ses
moyens et à contracter des dettes.
Par exemple, il emménage dans une maison dont le
loyer asséchera ses finances en quelques mois, ou
il paie des cours particuliers à ses filles.
Ses besoins financiers le poussent à
produire — des articles et des livres
— mais les revenus qu’il en tire sont
négligeables par rapport à ses besoins.
S’il s’en sort, c’est grâce à des héritages.
Il y a d’abord celui de sa femme.
Il y a ensuite le sien. Au milieu de
la quarantaine, il sort durablement
de la misère en touchant une grosse
part de l’héritage de ses parents.
Et enfin, il y a surtout tout l’argent que
lui envoie son meilleur ami, Engels !
C’est grâce à lui que la famille de
Marx survit dans la misère.
Friedrich Engels, c’est le coauteur
du fameux Manifeste du parti communiste.
Fils d’un industriel qui a fait fortune dans le
textile, Engels finance son ami parce qu’il
est convaincu que Marx a un grand destin,
que ses idées vont changer le monde.
Certaines années, il contribue à hauteur
des deux tiers aux revenus de la famille.
Un jour, Marx n’a même pas assez d’argent pour
expédier le manuscrit de sa Contribution
à la critique de l'économie politique à
l’éditeur — donc il envoie une nième lettre
à Engels pour lui demander de l’argent.
Il lui écrit cette phrase qui deviendra célèbre
: « Je ne pense pas qu'on ait jamais écrit sur
l'argent tout en en manquant à ce point ! ».
Cette anecdote est révélatrice
à plusieurs égards
— mais le plus intéressant à mes yeux,
c’est qu’elle nous fait penser que c’est
le rapport personnel de Marx à l’argent qui
explique sa théorie économique.
Travailler pour gagner de l’argent,
c’est un esclavage auquel Marx
ne veut pas se soumettre.
Subvenir à ses besoins grâce à des héritages,
ça ne fait pas très prolétaire…
Mais ce n’est pas la seule chose qui
ne fait pas prolétaire chez Marx.
À 25 ans, Karl Marx épouse
Jenny VON Westphalen.
Et le mot allemand « VON », ça
signifie « DE » en français.
Autrement dit, Marx se marie
avec une aristocrate.
La famille de Jenny fait même
partie de l’élite prussienne.
Ça non plus, ça ne fait pas très prolétaire…
Les biographes s’interrogeront
sur ce mariage.
Certains verront dans
l’attirance de Marx pour une aristocrate
un désir de s’affranchir du travail.
Mais la raison est bien plus simple
: Jenny était sa voisine ;
enfants, ils jouaient ensemble ; et ils ont
continué de se fréquenter à l’adolescence.
Une fois mariés, elle deviendra
sa collaboratrice.
Comme elle est, elle aussi,
une intellectuelle, Marx lui
parle de ses lectures et de ses idées.
Elle devient sa première lectrice et restera
la seule capable de déchiffrer
parfaitement son écriture.
Il lui fait même recopier ses textes avant
de les envoyer chez l'imprimeur.
Cette anecdote montre que le prolétariat
n’est pas le milieu social de Marx.
Certes, il aime sincèrement sa femme — mais
par elle, il se déconnecte de la partie de la
population qu’il prétend défendre.
D’ailleurs, leur mariage n’était pas
placé sous le signe de la révolution : ils ont
dépensé sans compter lors de leur lune de miel,
qu’ils ont passé sur les chutes du Rhin.
Dean Street est une rue du quartier de Soho,
au centre de Londres.
Aujourd’hui, c’est un des
quartiers les plus animés de la ville — mais à
l’époque, c’était un des plus mal famés.
Un des biographes de la femme de Marx a
surnommé Dean Street « la rue de la Mort ».
En effet, les conditions de vie des Marx sont si
misérables que leurs enfants tombent malades les
uns après les autres.